we all heard all this stuff about
Russian disinformation and Russian
interference in our elections China has
an entire military department dedicated
to this
I think this virus as terrible as it is
has been a wake-up call how can any
country does do business with China
fully trust them they can plain and
simple there's so many different things
to investigate why China well right now
there's a big propaganda battle China's
of course gained a significant control
over Hollywood they can then control
what is shown in our movies it is
changing the way you perceive something
at what point did you say I'm gonna go
much deeper than I am right now
it is a totalitarian regime that has no
problem throwing Muslim leaders and
slave camps tearing down churches of
house Christians that will use following
Gong practitioners is living sources for
organ transplants how is us being
bullied by Channel I knew the Chinese
regime regards the United States is its
number one enemy but things like
methamphetamine and other drugs were
coming from Wuhan say this is over with
post coronavirus and : 19 what's going
to change with our relationship with
China the Chinese people will riot they
will overturn police cars they will
curse the Communist Party they will
stand up against it I don't think the
Communist Party itself is going to
survive this did you ever think you
would make
for me here yeah why would you bet on
Goliath but we got plant a value caiman
given values contagious this world of
entrepreneurs we can't no value to
haters honey run homie look what I
become
[Music]
my guest today is Joshua Philip who is a
senior investigative reporter at The
Epoch Times he did a documentary that I
watched which at this point on all the
platforms combined whether it's Facebook
YouTube and their websites got over a
hundred million views and what he
studies and he researches and
investigates is on politics cyber
security and defense tie to China so
would that being said Joshua thanks for
being a guest on that Ament it's a real
pleasure some great stuff to talk about
I'm looking forward to it so let me ask
you what caused you to wanna there's so
many different things to investigate why
China well so my investigations on China
started way back in 20 or sorry 2008 and
it was actually unintentional to be
honest I had stumbled across some pretty
strange occurrences there were acts of
you know physical attacks taking place
in one of the big Chinese communities
and over the course of a few years I
uncovered what was what's now called and
very well known as the United Front work
department basically how the Chinese
regime extends its suppression and arms
into foreign communities working with
things like tongs these fraternal
organizations that basically run
Chinatown
you know organized crime you name it got
it so that's kind that's kind of what
prompted you so as you got in at what
point did you say I'm gonna go much
deeper than I am right now well it was a
step by step thing so when I first got
into this beat I mean it was stuff I'd
never heard of you know people were
telling me oh you know that guy's a spy
this guy's a spying on I mean I'm in
Chinatown I'm seeing people physically
attacking people I'm seeing these large
groups come out with signs and people
are getting death threats people are
coming up to me and they're telling you
know Chinese people they're telling me
oh they told me they can you know
threaten my family they told me they
could make me disappear and you know I
mean it's bizarre III never encountered
anything like this I had no idea how to
understand it and so for me the
investigation was more I had a lot of
questions and I wanted to figure out
what was going on and try to get to the
bottom of it over the course of time of
course after I uncovered the initial
pieces of it yes that these individuals
were of course being rallied
by the Chinese consulate Chinese
consulate general at the time panca you
we actually had some stories showing
that he was meeting with the individuals
encouraging them and so on
found out over time that you know this
is a bigger picture than what I thought
initially and over time I uncovered
what's now pretty well known which is
the Chinese regimes whole system of
unconventional warfare culture warfare
business warfare cyber warfare you name
it that's been the remainder so that's
what you've come to conclusion with now
how often have you been to China
yourself never I am I'm proudly
blacklisted as is epic times overall but
we do have offices in Hong Kong and
Taiwan though but mainland China we've
been blacklisted almost from the get-go
when you say blacklist is what does what
does blacklisted mean because people
have told me hey some of the stuff you
talk about could potentially get you
blacklisted what is what is blacklisted
well blacklisted for some media means of
course you have no visa they don't tell
you why you can't go there you're never
allowed to go you know do research there
or reporting there for us blacklisted
started I think in 2000 soon after we
launched at Park Times Chinese officials
or Chinese police knocked on the door of
you know some of our Chinese staff who
were in China arrested the entire office
or editors spent 10 years in prison and
they tortured him one of your editors
from epoch down spent 10 years in prison
and tortured them yep and was he freed
he was several years ago he was freed
yes and what stories did he share with
you that when he was there for 10 years
what did they do to him so when he first
got out he did talk with me I don't know
the details about the torture its Jesus
was probably good five years ago now I
interviewed him I can't remember there
were some public reports about his case
of course some of these you know
journalist journalists rights
organizations did have some things on
him but you know he his spirit wasn't
crushed he he's still very much about
getting the truth out in China somehow
he hasn't been arrested again so that's
good be good to know
where does he know is he in the states
or conquer Taiwan last I've heard he's
still in the mainland he's spilling
money but he's not involved with that
buck dimes anymore after he after he got
out of court
because you know they have him under
surveillance Oh got it so he cannot be
doing what he's doing with you guys
because he's under surveillance
so it'll last very long yeah so from the
moment you did the documentary which
went viral and was shared by everybody
around the world I'm sure a lot of
people contacted you a lot of different
people tell us sending their own stories
here's what I know here's what I know
what's changed from the stories and the
document of which by the way yeah
general Spaulding there yeah Gordon
Changu yeah Duke dr. Judy my kibbutz
there which is how I saw and found out
about dr. judy was through your document
I believe you were one of the first ones
in the last you know during this era of
the China and coronavirus that we heard
about dr. judy where other people have
been out interviewing her what's changed
from seeing the documentary from China
to today
well since the documentary was released
there have actually been a lot of
reports corroborating what we've said
you know there of course now
investigations is going into it
specifically on individuals that we
directly point to such as this dr. Shi
jangly this Batwoman of China as being
one of the possible central figures in
this entire thing the u.s. is launching
multiple investigations that is reported
for example they cut they cut funding to
an NIH program that was going to China
dr. Jia that's it sorry this dr. Shi
generally is actually named in some of
the reports on that there was a pentagon
program that was also you know it's
being investigated right now sending
money to China other ones
many of them are mentioning dr. Shi
generally there's investigations into
some of the US universities such as in
Texas and also again naming directly dr.
Shi Jin Lee and this Wuhan Institute of
biology and so it does appear that we at
the very least contributed some evidence
that may be helping some of these
investigations we'll have to see and of
course a lot of media came out after we
published the video doing interviews
such as for example Washington Post had
a had an article noting that in 2018
there were State Department cables
warning of security problems at that
laboratory more articles like that have
come out there have been some other ones
exclusives and other media really just
corroborating what we said as well
so what is your biggest concern what's
your biggest comes from with China today
you're right you were so deep into it
what's your biggest concern so when when
it comes to the way I view the Chinese
regime it's maybe a bit different from a
lot of how a lot of people view it the
Chinese regime regards the United States
as its number-one enemy the very
existence of a country that you know is
based on the ideas of say individual
rights does defend internationally to
some extent human rights does believe in
this idea that if given basic freedoms
people can create a prosperous society
these things are antithetical to the
narratives and the practices of the
Chinese Communist Party it tells people
that they are not capable of creating a
harmonious and functioning society if
people are given freedom like we have
here and so challenging that attacking
the United States undermining this
perception is a huge part of what the
Chinese regime is doing and when it
comes to their systems of warfare of
course when we think war normally we
think tanks guns soldiers you know Jets
missiles these kinds of things when
you're dealing with the Chinese
Communist Party they're talking about
culture they're talking about drugs
they're talking about business warfare
cyber they're talking about the basic
perceptions things like they have the
three Warfare's doctrine psychological
warfare media warfare and legal warfare
how do you how do you alter
international perceptions of issues how
do you manipulate the say basic
perceptions of a country in order to
support or oppose what they want you to
support or oppose what you said
psychological warfare media warfare what
was a third one legal warfare so the
other three warfare is a doctrine that
would be part of three wars reporters
dr. one-dimensional go through each one
of them on how they sure so I'll use the
South trying to see you as an example
because this is a very clear example
that playing out the three Warfare's
doctrine is actually adopted into the
Chinese military's strategy it is an
officially adopted military strategy and
it's based on three points its beta it's
based essentially around manipulating
the psychological and legal standpoints
in order to obtain objectives I mean
this sounds complicated let me explain
it now on the surface psychological
warfare is not necessarily propaganda
it's not necessary
misleading you psychological warfare is
altering the conclusions you come to
when observing information it is
changing the way you perceive something
media warfare is a manipulation and
control of say news outlets social media
any outlet of information legal warfare
is the manipulation of legal systems
they call it law fair sometimes but
let's look at this in practice okay
so when we look at the South China Sea
the Chinese regime use this to the tea
is a military strategy what do they do
they start going in to the South China
Sea building military bases building
artificial islands putting up missile
defense systems you name it very hostile
actions even challenging other nations
putting up you know an air defense zone
saying other countries can enter their
airspace without checking with them
first this is you know it's conquering
traditional conquering that's what they
were doing just taking territory saying
it's are saying nobody can come in
unless they tell us first and we give
them permission but how did they take it
that is where the three war first comes
in on the psychological warfare part
they created a narrative and what was
the narrative the narrative was one of
historical ownership of the region one
that painted China as a victim and gave
them of course the perceived rights and
even say justified actions of going in
and take in this territory they said
they had historical ownership of this
region it was taken from them from them
unjustly by Japan by these different
deals after World War two that was a
narrative they used then they what do
they do after that they go into the
media warfare element it's very easy to
manipulate the media extremely easy if
you're a country like China all you need
to do it will two things one is you have
your former officials or current
officials go to any big news outlet and
tell them I got an exclusive story for
you I'll tell you the real story of
what's happening in China and they're
gonna publish everything that person
says the other one is if they media
writes a critical story of China if
they're sit there talking about it they
can easily just have you know an
academic or say a top level of Chinese
official go to them and say your article
was racist your article was offensive
you know you don't understand China have
you ever been to China how dare you
write about my kind
and that journalist is going to get on
his knees and say everything that person
tells them that he's going to be eating
out of their hands and you see it all
the time and so that's media warfare and
then when you get into legal warfare
that's the maintaining the battle within
the legal realm so it does not enter the
diplomatic or political or sorry the
diplomatic or the hot war realm and so
again South trying to see you have the
Chinese regime taking military action
building military bases being you know
taking very hostile action against other
ships sinking you know sometimes even
ramming and there were cases of you know
for example other ships from other
countries being sunk Montemayor mainly
fishing fishing fishing vessels and
things like that very hostile actions
regardless though but they kept it from
entering the military realm by
maintaining it as a legal battle and so
they locked it in the international
courts eventually of course the courts
fettino ruled against China said it does
not have historical ownership of this
territory but by that time they'd
already mostly won the International
battle of perception and in addition to
that they said well in Chinese law by
our laws we still have rights to do this
and you know if you want to challenge us
come to China's coords come to our
courts and challenge us and of course
they were you know they control the
court system down to the most minut
levels there's no way you're gonna win a
battle in China like that how is us
being bullied by China right now on many
fronts so if you want to get into the
broad picture of it the say the type of
real bullying if you were to ask me
that's when you get into things like
economic theft you get into things like
culture you get into things like drugs
you know again what they call
unrestricted warfare and it's based on
it you know this is actually a name of a
book it's a lot of China experts talk
about it as being kind of the the basic
framework through which China has waged
an unconventional war on the United
States
so 1999 two chinese Colonels wrote a
book called unrestricted warfare where
they proposed a new system of war
without morals and it's based on a very
simple way of thinking now if you want
to get into the said you know
nitty-gritty the gist of it we could go
on forever
talking about all the different forms of
unconventional war they run you know
names all across the board everything
you could think of being targeted but it
comes down to this it's a perception of
saying what would you want to achieve
through warfare and how can you achieve
those exact same goals without engaging
in open combat and so for example
culture warfare
you know China's of course gained a
significant control over Hollywood
not just through say manipulation say
forcing them to abide by Chinese laws
when it comes to censorship and
propaganda if they want to get their
films into China which is a huge market
for Hollywood especially right now when
you know films aren't doing as hot - you
know for example buying up in buying up
parts of ownership and say production
houses talent houses buying AMC Theaters
for example these types of things you
know they can then control what is shown
in our movies for example they can't if
they want to get into China they can't
show China and a negative light they
can't show the US military in a positive
light if they want to get into China
they need to maintain say you know at
least one scene in China they have to
have at least one Chinese actor or
actress and so on certain requirements
for that and of course the Chinese
regime Xi Jinping actually back when
they launched a lot of these operations
came out and said the United States is
launching a culture war on China and
said that they needed to retaliate they
talk about the stuff openly when it
comes to drug warfare for example how do
you destroy the moral fabric of a
society we talk about things like these
synthetic drugs fentanyl that comes from
China but what's actually not really is
well-known is that most of our drugs
come from China the drug cartels in
Latin America they get their precursor
chemicals from China in fact there been
some reports saying that they're having
trouble manufacturing because a lot of
their labs that are getting their
precursor chemicals from for things like
methamphetamine and other drugs were
coming from Wuhan the epicenter of this
virus and so you know you name it across
the board on that this is how this is
the real way they're bullying America
ecstasy is coming from China I haven't
heard ecstasy but a lot of the synthetic
ones would yes
so in order for things to for me to say
where the world is a little bit more
comfortable with China
it would mean their foundation would
need to change right meaning because
their foundation of communism control
controlling media controlling everything
that the people do not allow free press
free speech you don't have a Facebook a
YouTube or Twitter any social media
platforms that are open and China for
the public to use you know and if that
doesn't happen how can any country
that's doing business with China fully
trust them they can't blame and simple
and of course it's it's interesting now
to see that a lot of countries are
starting to finally realize this I think
this virus as terrible as it is has been
a wake-up call to a lot of countries
seeing that you know there for example
in the UK and Australia where they're
calling for investigations into the
Chinese regime and the Chinese regime is
coming out and threatening them openly
this is for example a big a big story in
Australia right now where they're you
know they're calling for investigations
if it the origin of this virus looking
and again into this Wuhan laboratory as
a possible origin the Chinese regime is
threatening them with punishment saying
we're not going to send Chinese students
to Australia anymore we're gonna hit you
economically if you keep calling for
this in the UK and Australia say they're
saying the masks that the Chinese regime
once wore this friendly mask has fallen
off and finally seeing it for what it is
it is a country dedicated to the defense
of its narratives it is a totalitarian
regime that is no problem for example
throwing Muslim leaders and slave camps
that you know doesn't mind tearing down
churches of house Christians that will
use Falun Gong practitioners people
trying to be good people is living
sources for organ transplants that can
lock down Tibet and still amidst all of
this be portrayed so much positively by
the media saying China is changing when
they have not changed one drop how much
you think things are going to change
moving forward post coronavirus and copa
19 with foreign relations and what i
mean by this is say this is over with
let's just say this is over with what's
gonna change with our relationship with
china a lot it's gonna change a whole
lot it's gonna change now let's let's
look at the overall situation this by
that personally to start I do not think
the Chinese regime is going to survive
this I don't think they're gonna make it
through this and they're facing pressure
from multiple angles and women when I
say this now if you were to ask me a
couple years ago I I wouldn't I would
not have said this but now this is where
it's heading and here's there's a
situation this virus came at the worst
possible time for the Chinese regime
strategically it happened right at the
height of the Hong Kong protest when the
when the authoritarian nature of the
Chinese regime was being called out by
the Chinese people themselves when the
people were waking up when they showed
you know people in Hong Kong knowing
about the Tiananmen Square massacre
decided that they are willing to stand
up to that regime risking an action like
that from the regime seeing signs of you
know that they can make you disappear
for example 2 million people that have
become out of a you know a city of about
7 million and so a lot you know 6 or 7
million if anything anyway it and so a
lot you know a huge portion of the
population the Chinese regime was
terrified these protests are going to
spread into the mainland then you have
in Taiwan a landslide election against
the party that is opposed against the
party that was supportive of the Chinese
regime and so the anti-ccp party anti
Chinese Communist Party party and in
Taiwan won the election and then in
mainland China you had business she had
businesses shutting down you had people
of course you know losing their jobs
because this whole trial us-china trade
war the situation for them was was the
worst possible time then you have a
virus come out that completely shuts
down the Chinese economy causes a lot of
social instability and when you're a
totalitarian regime that has maintained
essentially social control through two
things one is fear and the other one is
through finance and both of these things
are suddenly destabilized where people
become willing to stand up to you
because they're more afraid of your
totalitarian systems but you know
they're they believe that standing up
against you will bring them better
outcomes than living under your heel you
know that's where China is right now
people are no longer afraid of protest
against or they're no longer afraid to
call it out we had reports of people in
Wuhan the epicenter of this virus going
out on their balconies and shouting
curses into the night sky
the Chinese regime because we was the
only outlet they had in terms of calling
it out they no longer fear the Chinese
regime of many parts and so when it
comes to that internally they are very
much destabilized if it comes to
external polity external politics
countries are pulling their factories
out of China they're calling out China
diplomatically they're talking about
decoupling with China they're talking
about securing their sourcing for
different productions for example Japan
is actually paying companies to move
their productions out of China the
Chinese regime isn't gonna I don't think
financially I don't think ideologically
and I don't think internally among the
way people in their own country perceive
them I don't think it has a whole lot
going for and I honestly again I don't
think the Communist Party itself is
gonna survive this you don't think they
are no not at all
tell me why you say that because you
know you have Gordon Chang that you had
on he wrote a company he wrote a book
called the collapse of China and he
wrote that book a long time ago and it
never happened it's been over two
decades since he wrote that book and
it's still around China's getting
stronger
pre coronavirus that we're getting
stronger why do you think that that
Empire is gonna collapse well it's
because what is the foundation of the
Empire right what is the foundation of
it outside of China the maintain they
maintained their social controls
basically through soft power soft power
financial interest and then you know
some political subversion getting
politicians in their pockets I mentioned
before the sorry the United Front
working Department the one that I had
been a lot of reporting on you know one
of the ways that works is by inviting
politicians business leaders back to
China you know getting them business
deals maybe getting them caught in honey
traps where they might mean I may sleep
with the young girl and have video
cameras record the whole thing this is
very a very common practice of the
Chinese regime that so when it comes to
political influence when it comes to
soft power a la that's being called out
right now when it comes to their control
and universities for example just as a
part of this there are multiple
investigations being done right now into
for example different academics who have
received gifts from China that they had
not previously disclosed there are a lot
of public reports about this the
Department of Education is investigating
it
that for example this dr. Charles Lieber
the head of the chemistry department at
Harvard was actually caught in that for
example he was taking something like 50k
a month from the Chinese regime and was
being was working through its thousand
talents program now when it comes to the
business side a lot of companies are
already pulling out of China it's not
financially feasible to stay in China
and you know really the benefit of being
there isn't as much as it used to be you
can go to Cambodia you can go to Mexico
you can go to you know the Vietnam and
manufactured just as cheap without
having to deal with all the crazy
politics and so companies are pulling
out and once they pull out what ad
Center do they have to ever go back in
we also saw for example with the face
masks in China US company you know
running in China making these global
face masks China demonstrated that they
can nationalize a company like that that
they can take it over and forbid an
American country from selling to America
during a time of crisis and so now in
the US are talking about securing supply
chains making sure that that never
happens again in many countries are
doing the same thing when it comes to
the Chinese regime trying to buy up you
know different countries buy them off
through things like debt traps one belt
one road initiatives things like this
building infrastructure in countries
getting them and again debt traps they
can never pay off and then through that
being able to take over Natural
Resources critical infrastructure etc
that's also being called out that's also
being stopped in fact the coronavirus
has basically derailed the entire one
belt one road initiative and then you
have also different countries including
the UK including India including many
others working on things to forbid
Chinese foreign direct investment
because they're worried the Chinese
regime is going to manipulate the
current financial environment where
countries where you know the stock
markets are crashing to do hostile
takeovers of companies and so you know
it's almost like everybody sees them for
what they are at this point everybody
knows what they're doing at this point
the narratives no longer work the mask
again has fallen off they're seeing the
Chinese regime for what it is and
they're not playing the games anymore do
you think that's going to cause them to
collapse because III think I think they
have I mean think about it
what 1.5 billion people there 1.6
billion whatever that number is how many
people are controlled by the current
philosophy of running the country and
what I mean by that is influential
people not voters not populace not just
the average working class person that's
in China I'm talking about people that
are part of the Communist ECP the party
that want this thing to continue that's
a pretty big you know big party big big
army that they have you think they're
gonna let this machine go down for that
to happen it needs to massive revolt how
does that happen though I think it's
already happening I think it's already
happening internally I think so yeah
with the leadership team oh absolutely
yeah I mean a lot of times we get a lot
you know we have so it's interesting of
course we started in 2000 and of course
we've from the very GetGo never folded
to the Chinese regime's pressures you
know we've we've kind of established
ourselves as you know the China experts
we've never folded to the Chinese regime
we've always been very critical of that
we've always exposed what it does and
one of the effects of that is that
whenever anyone wants to defect when
everyone whenever anyone wants to get
information out whenever anyone wants to
leak a document they typically come to
us we get regularly almost every day
leaked documents coming out of China we
get top-level officials telling us
what's really happening there the real
picture of China is that many people
within the Communist Party they no
longer believe in the Communist Party
they no longer fear the Chinese
Communist Party people now you know even
even within say where things are at with
this virus I'll give you a few examples
you have local governments defying top
level political guide guidelines for
example when they tried opening up Wuhan
and you had Chinese people trying to go
back to work try crossing over and what
are the nearby provinces the local
government stopped them while the
Chinese regime top-level powers was
trying to you know open things up and
create this image of harmony local
government apparently sent police forces
there was a ride on one of the bridges
now this showed two things one is local
government defined top-level politics
and the other side of it you had a show
the Chinese people will riot they will
over
turn police cars they will curse the
Communist Party they will stand up
against it because again when you're a
communist country that has maintained
social control basically through fear
and through financial interest both of
these things are destabilized and so
what is the basis of power for the
regime and the basis of it maintaining
its totalitarian system again this
narrative that the party knows better
than you do right the party can make
better decisions than you can and so of
course the party can choose you know
your basic decisions in life of course
the party can dictate what you choose to
believe when people no longer believe in
the competence of the party again that
is destabilized and so the Chinese
regime is facing all of these things
right now
you know one of the things I'm curious
about I'm trying to search it to see if
I can find us online is what is the
average age of population and China
meaning is it more younger older middle
age where is that age demographic I'm
not sure to be honest but because of the
one-child policy they do have they do
have an issue with you know an aging
population and they do have an issue of
the younger generation they're not being
big enough to basically hold it up and
of course they got rid of the one China
policy there there's some nuances to it
it's a bit complicated but what they
found is a lot of people are still not
having kids not as much as they
anticipated and so you still have a
pretty big crisis with that I only ask
the questions because if if a populace
is going to revolt against the nation it
has to be a younger populace because the
older populace gets too conservative and
worried about the consequences because
the older generations worry about their
kids and grandkids and when you're
younger in your 20s you're not really
worried about anybody you're willing to
revolt so if they got a younger audience
they could but if they got an older
aging you really need to have a lot of
audacity to go up against a regime like
that I'm from Iran and I can tell you
there's a lot of strength when the
younger audience decides to go up
against an older this is how a Ron Paul
and a Bernie Sanders were able to get
very close to being a nominee because
they were able to get the younger
audience organized and motivated to to
get him going so yeah
would be one part if they can do that
maybe there's a potential if not I just
see them bullying too many people I mean
those things you were explaining about
saying having the powerful people come
in and have sex with a younger girl and
then record and use it as a threat for
more pain $50,000 to professors or
people that are working right now to
positively make them look good how much
of that do you think is slowing down in
America meaning China having people
internally working on media's or buying
media or teachers or professors or
influential people how much of that is
still happening today it's a huge
massive scale not just in the US but in
just about every country so for example
in Canada they had the sidewinder report
from their equivalent to the CIA which
detailed how the Chinese regime had
basically bought off a lot of
politicians in Australia this is
actually discussion in the mainstream
you know news outlets it's it's part of
the cultural discussion right now the
degree to which the Chinese regime has
bought control of their local
politicians the degree to which the
Chinese regime is able to influence the
society through things like this not
just at the political level but even at
the universities and things like that in
the u.s. I think the discussion is just
starting
it's just now being I think the lid is
being opened and I think people are
going to start seeing the extent to
which the Chinese regime has gained
control over a lot of our politicians
has gained control over a lot of the
decision-making this country not just on
the financial level but even on some of
the direct levels when it comes to
things like the Confucius Institutes
Chinese funded you know language and
culture programs at universities where
university to city are taking money from
the Chinese regime when these
Institute's can implement all kinds of
things like censorship and such they're
being called out in a lot of countries
Sweden for example just ban the last
Confucius Institute from the country
when it comes to things like the torch
program the thousand talents program the
973 program the 211 program essentially
a basket of programs the Chinese regime
has official open programs to subvert
our academic institutions and our
business institutions they they open
their open about these things and so the
Chinese regime is very aggressive with
this it not only is it aggressive with
it it does even try to hide it in the
usb
for so long it has acted with audacity
it is not afraid you know it wasn't
afraid of people looking into and trying
to figure these things out this is an
example last I checked even what a few
weeks ago the Chinese consulate web site
in New York has the United Front listed
as one of its operations it has the
liaison department listed as one of its
operations the liaison department is out
of the general political department this
is the political warfare branch of the
Chinese military we all heard all this
stuff about you know Russian
disinformation and Russian interference
in our elections China has an entire
military department dedicated to this
the general political department run
through the run through the liaison
department operating openly in New York
City through the Chinese consulate
website there's a think tank project
2049 Institute Institute had a whole
report actually on the liaison
department so how many similarities do
you see for you to make a you know
statement to say you believe they're
gonna go down and they're not gonna stay
like this I'm like similarly do see
between them and Russia pre communism
imposed communism when Russia was going
strong with communism and on all of a
sudden hey you know bring the wall down
and the next thing you know the
philosophy changes this is post
Gorbachev and things start kind of
opening up a little bit more how much
similarity do you see between Russia and
China the old Russia with the current
China the situation is actually very
similar on many fronts and so you know
whereas the Chinese regime has these
systems of overt warfare under under the
Soviets they called that ideological
subversion this unrestricted warfare
program so it so called it ideological
subversion it's the same thing trying
the Chinese regime has carried the torch
of it when it comes to business ties
it's very much the same thing you had a
lot of big corporations manufacturing in
Russia you had a lot of the same you
know overlapping business interests
although on the political level there
was a lot of conflict when it came to
the academic subversion you know the
commmunity communists in the soviet
union were pushing for the global
communist revolution and a lot of
academics and a lot of people in
hollywood worried
working with the Soviet regime and of
course at that time if you were you know
a communist party member for example it
meant you were loyal for the Soviet the
Soviet regime the system is is exactly
the same the only difference is that at
the time a lot of people recognized the
Soviet Union as a hostile nation to the
United States because he had threats of
nuclear war it was a lot more military
you know the perception was a lot more
military based the Chinese regime
doesn't have that perception and so
they're able to operate with a lot more
impunity they're able to operate with a
lot you know a cleaner face essentially
for the world to look at but essentially
the situation underneath the hood is all
the same it's exactly the same and just
like the collapse of the Soviet Union I
frankly believe that the collapse of the
Chinese Communist Party is going to
catch a lot of people by surprise
timeline what's your timeline timeline
okay here's here's how I see things
playing out United States is going to
launch an investigation into the origins
of this virus and into whether the
Chinese regime mishandled information
for example through censoring it which
allowed to spread internationally left
many countries unprepared for it many
countries are calling them out even Iran
notably is calling out the Chinese
regime for this for lying to them for
misleading them about how dangerous this
virus was about telling them it was no
big deal and of course a lot of the
leadership of God have caught the virus
and a lot of leadership is dying from it
in fact there been some reports nobody
how strange is it it seems to be
especially targeting the leadership of
Iran Iran is one of the Chinese James
closest allies you have the same thing
with Russia they're kicking out Chinese
nationals they're expatriated them
they're bright you know Russia as well
but a lot of Chinese PPE this protective
gear for the you know medical front Nina
medical frontline workers that's being
found to be non-functional a lot of
countries are angry at the Chinese
regime right now many countries the
United States very likely front lining
it with front lining are going to launch
investigations into this we know that at
the very least regardless of how the
virus got out intentional or not lab or
lab origin or not the Chinese regime
lied to the world the Chinese regime
censored information it disappeared or
arrested individuals who tried worn
the world about it and very likely
you're going to have the Chinese regime
get called out on this it's going to be
called out with these investigations and
then right on the heels of that you're
going to have international lawsuits and
of course there's a question of whether
or not you can hold a country liable
when it comes to these lawsuits but what
we're gonna see very likely are
sanctions you're gonna see all the
manufacturing getting pulled out of
China of not just the US but many
different countries supply chains
pulling out of China for many different
countries and you're gonna see what is
very likely going to be an economic
collapse inside China and you're gonna
see a lot of people out of work very
unhappy with the Chinese regime who is
belief in the regime has already faded
who already no longer believe their
regimes narratives you already see
through its lies and its propaganda the
Chinese people are not stupid you know
they know they know they're getting lied
to as if you read what Chinese medicines
say about it on a daily basis it's a
joke for them you know they they joke
about it now that when it comes to where
things are heading internationally
there's going to be a decoupling the
Chinese regimes you know facade of this
friendly veneer it's all going to fall
off the Chinese people themselves are
very likely going to stop supporting it
and we're gonna see a few different
possibilities one is a full collapse of
the Chinese regime we're very much like
the collapse of the Soviet Union they
try to transition to a different system
that is course dangerous what we saw
with the Soviets was you know it
collapses they moved to a free market
economy but who has all the money it's
all the former Communist Party leaders
and of course they just buy up the
natural resources and the businesses and
create an oligarchy basically run by the
same individuals I hopefully China will
have learned it's lesson from that they
will not repeat the same mistake maybe
they'll find a better a better way of
going forward other possibilities you'll
see a balkanization where local
governments basically stopped listening
to higher the higher levels of the
Chinese Communist Party we're already
seeing signs of that where there's you
know they're not cooperating they're not
listening to higher authorities
when the Chinese adeno top-level
government says implement this policy if
they're not listening to it we've seen a
lot of cases like this and so there is a
possible possibility of balkanization
and i
I think through these or a combination
of these means yeah within maybe a year
I don't think we're gonna have the
Chinese Communist Party anymore you say
within a year that's a bold statement
yeah and then I really think that's
where it's heading
based on these based on these different
trajectories a year you're saying okay
so here's the other question how United
are we on this belief that you just
shared in us are Democrats and
Republicans on the same page about China
today it does seem so it
chara is one of the is one of the few
bipartisan issues not just when it comes
to say the way it's handled this virus
you know I think with this virus it's a
little complicated because it's being
politicized to to a degree a lot of the
last clean of the Democrats for example
they do want to say Trump mishandled
this and some of the articles you've
seen from you know big media which do
lean left they've actually been used a
lot by the Chinese regime and its
propaganda because you know they're
trying to shift blame to the United
States saying the United States did not
handle things well and so on that's one
of their big narratives but really at
the top level when it comes down to it
it does seem like this is a bipartisan
issue you know left and right Democrats
Republicans they do seem to be
recognizing the Chinese Communist Party
for what it is in fact there been some
public polls on this asking you know
people you know what do they think of
the Chinese Communist Party what do they
think of China's handling of this and
for the most part it seems people are on
the same page
Republicans and Democrats that they see
through it not to be the biggest thing
you're on the same page this can happen
but if the media is constantly pinning
saying no it's not you China's Paul it's
USS T'Pol no it's not us China's well if
we're not united I don't foresee that
taking place because what helped us in
different countries go through a
revolution was a backing from a you know
behemoth country like us to say yes we
support the revolution if US doesn't do
that China is now going to go through
that process that they will be bullied
by the government I believe so over and
over and over again by the way how much
have you looked into what happened
recently when Yahoo put out the article
with this recent doctor the research
on a virgin make him very significant
coronavirus finding shot to death how
much have you investigated that so far
only a little bit but I can I can give
some additional insights into that if
you'd like please just in terms of the
periphery of issues like this now of
course there was this doctor who was
allegedly on the front lines of you know
making some big breakthrough with this
virus I did have some people in email me
saying they knew this individual after
that came out I haven't I haven't
verified it yet what I've been told is
he was working on a vaccine and he was
very close to completing that vaccine
that that's what I've been told Kent I
haven't fully verified it yet so take it
for what it's worth it's not clear who
the individual was who killed him it
does appear to be someone who knew him
now a few different pieces of this now
for me this does bring to mind a few
different investigations I've done for
example there was a case for example
several ago several years ago now where
there was a murder in Texas of an entire
Chinese family father mother children
all murdered and what appeared to be a
very professional hit job you know it
looked like a professional hit job
basically X you know they were all
executed there were reports in China
that it came out that Joo young Kong the
former securities are called for that
murder that was never verified but there
were there were reports in China saying
and at the time Joo young Kong was
facing trial through this whole
anti-corruption campaign he was being
purged by the top-level leadership and
so it is possible that hits like this
can take place allegedly the individual
in Texas who was killed was involved in
some big oil oil deal that was going on
that Joo Hong Kong was wrapped up in I
did look into that a little bit he did
have he did have a lot of overlap with
certain high-level communist party
figures including ties to Jiangsu min
the former head of the Chinese Communist
Party which would have been Julian
Kong's
political camp because there are
different factions in China that was
never fully verified but again there
were reports in China about that a few
other cases just as an example I've
never actually talked about this
publicly
but in New York for example when I was
doing a lot of my investigations one of
my sources was a former Chinese spy who
actually helped the Chinese regime
develop a lot of its overseas say overt
espionage systems for example working
with these fraternal organizations which
we call tongs he told me about several
murders that had taken place and these
murders were allegedly tied to you know
spy vs. spy things among Chinese
military spies and Chinese government
spies in fighting on foreign soil namely
in this case US soil and the two of the
murders were pretty brutal one of them
was an individual they tied him to a
chair cut his throat and then set him on
fire with him all the evidence was of
course destroyed the other individual
was a Chinese woman who was killed the
individual killed there was apparently a
boyfriend and he cut out one of her
organs and had it on his person when he
was arrested now when I was trying to
investigate this some very strange
things came up well one is it ended
basically because people I needed I
would have needed to interview were dead
or gone or would not talk to me and
because for example in the fire evidence
was destroyed but the people who did
talk to me told me the same thing
they said that this was that you know
for example one of the individuals was a
spy of Chinese government spy and the
individual who killed that person was
also a Chinese spy but it was infighting
between military spies and government
spies point being on with between these
two cases you these people do things
like that to each other whether the if
the juyeong kong case was true that you
know killing an entire family in texas
having them killed through a hit job
which was what was alleged in china and
some of these reports you know that
might have been the case you do have
suicides sometimes very bizarre suicides
when there are investigations underway
into the Chinese regime for example when
Huawei I was first being called out when
you know this top-level Huawei executive
was arrested in in Canada for example
you know you do have things like there
are people going
themselves and people do suspect that
maybe the foul play was involved yeah
the difference but this is the guy that
killed him when in the car and then
killed himself so I don't know if it was
that much of a hit shot because what
hitman kills themselves that's their
business you know so yeah well there was
something more you know motivation I
don't know what it was I'm curious you
know what comes out of it with where
this goes by the way final thoughts I'll
give it to you is what what you know as
you're going this is this is what you do
some people wake up in the morning and
they're stockbrokers all they do is
study the market some people wake up in
the morning they're doctors all they do
is read articles on what's going on with
the field they're part of some people
wake up in the morning they're in real
estate they read every article having to
do with real estate what is the latest
you know about what's going on with
China right now in regards with US and
China well right now there's a big
propaganda battle this is this is the
big area right now the United States is
of course calling for investigations
into the Chinese regime conducting
investigations there are international
calls you know Europe different
countries in the EU UK Australia Canada
I mean you name it they're calling for
investigations and the Chinese regime is
trying to challenge those investigations
through threats through diplomatic
threats they're trying to challenge
those investigations through financial
those investigations name you know
especially through this new propaganda
push what they're trying to shift blame
and say the United States did not handle
its response to the virus well and
they're trying to say the Chinese the
Chinese regime was being responsible
held off the virus for two months while
the rest of the world could good that
prepare for it and of course that's very
easily debunked the Chinese regime was
you know lying to the world about the
severity of it was relying to the world
about human to human transmission
covered up it you know covered up the
fact there was human human transmission
even when they knew it was the case and
then in the meantime before they alerted
the world went and had you know actually
through the United Front of Matt a
matter of fact there were some reports
in Canada saying the United Front was
involved in this had all their foreign
you know networks go and buy up all the
PPE this protective gear before they
told the world about it and so they were
able to court corner the entire global
market
these protective medical gear you know
this is where it's at this narrative
battle and it already pretty much lost
the narrative battle it seems it's gonna
be very interesting what happens next
obviously everybody's following very
closely how can people find you Joshua
they can find my show crossroads with
Joshua Phillip on YouTube they can also
go to use the epic times calm th EE P o
CH T IME s calm we're gonna put his
links beau about it with you searching
as Joshua Philip with two PS 1 l 2 peas
1 l just keep that part amount when
you're searching him Joshua again thank
you so much for making the time to be
guest on value Taemin hey my pleasure
thank you so what do you think about
China at this point of the game I mean
we've seen so many different things
about China do you agree with them when
he says within a year he thinks the
Chinese regime is gonna collapse I
thought I was one of the stronger points
that he made and I'm curious to know if
you agree with him that that could
happen within your comment below Amato
if you enjoyed this interview have two
other interviews I want you to watch one
of them is with Gordon Cheng who is a
lawyer that lived in China for 15 20
years and he did business there and he's
actually in the documentary with the
epoch times with Joshua Phillip click if
you want to watch that and then if you
haven't seen my interview with Daniel
DiMartino booth that was picked up
around the world got around 20 million
views in different languages different
platforms if you've not seen what she
said about China click on this and if
you've not subscribed to the channel
please do so thanks for watching
everybody
take care bye bye
you
[Music]